on continue avec artie arthur s'il veut
pardon artur silva voilà professeur
d'économie politique à l'université
laval bonsoir monsieur sylvain
mathieu filion on va parler de swift
avec vous ce city for worldwide
interbank
l'acronyme comment ça fonctionne et ça
sert à quoi
en fait derrière l'acronyme se cache
tout simplement un système de messagerie
interbancaire qui permet de résoudre les
les dettes qu'il peut y avoir d'une
banque vers le haut par exemple lorsque
vous faites un transfert d'une blanche
guérineau tsala passer par un ordre qui
va passer par le système swift qui est
extrêmement sécurisé suffisamment pour
ce genre de procédure et donc est
largement utilisé onze mille banques et
institutions financières utilisent ce
système la demande
absolument toutes les banques que vous
utilisez probablement dans votre vie
courante utilise swift si vous avez déjà
fait un pas un virement bancaire vers le
compte de quelqu'un d'autre dans une
banque au au québec ou ailleurs vous
avez probablement dû remplir le code
swift de la banque du destinataire pour
indiquer comment allait se dérouler ce
virement tout à fait donc on voit ça si
on décide et d'éjecter la réussite de ce
système là comme une arme économique
absolument puissante ça voudrait dire
quoi pour la russie
concrètement vous vous voyez ça comme
les virements interpersonnelles par
exemple la russie voit ça aussi comme un
moyen de résoudre un ensemble de
paiement entre par exemple pour payer
une une exportations de pétrole vers le
vers l'europe l'europe perret via un
virement bancaire s virement serait
ordonnée via le système swift donc
toutes les exportations de la russie ne
pourrait plus être rémunéré au moins
dans le court terme de même l'ensemble
les transferts financiers seraient
bloqués au moins dans le court terme par
cette mesure donc c'est effectivement
une sorte d'armes nucléaires qui
pourraient coûter plusieurs points de
pib d'un pays comme la russie cela dit
la france dit que ce serait sa dernière
option mais c'est une option
l'allemagne n'est pas très ouverte à
l'idée pourquoi
l'ensemble des pays européens en fait
sont sceptiques face à cette idée et on
les comprend d'une certaine manière
parce que ce serait presque aussi
coûteux pas tout à fait ce serait
presque aussi coûteux pour les
partenaires commerciaux et financiers de
la russie de mettre en oeuvre une
politique comme ça alors collectivement
le pouce très sensiblement de même de
manière individuelle évidemment c'est
partager donc la france l'allemagne
pourrait voir par exemple très difficile
l'achat d'un certain nombre de
commodités qui viennent de russie
pourrait aussi voir très difficile le
remboursement de dette russe qui
passeraient normalement par le cv par le
système bancaire et ça évidemment c'est
quelque chose qui semble coûteux pour
l'instant pour les pays occidentaux mais
si par exemple la russie devait être
éjecté de ce système là elle pourrait se
tourner vers la chine pour canaliser les
pma advenant un blocage ce serait quoi
leurs hôtes de la chaîne selon vous de
répondre à certains
en fait seulement dans une certaine
mesure dans le système swift n'a pas
vraiment d'alternative pour l'instant
dans le monde entier il y a même un
système russe qui joue sensiblement de
même rôle mais vous êtes vous l'avait
dit pour l'instant le système sud swift
réunit onze mille banque 11000
institutions financières dans le monde
toutes les banques chinoises les banques
russes les banques européennes les
banques canadiennes sont dans le système
serait le système russe ne permet de le
faire le lien avec presque aucune banque
étrangère le système chinois qui a des
liens avec le système russe pareil est
beaucoup plus limité dans son dans son
étendue donc en gros les la question
c'est de renchérir l'ensemble de rendre
plus compliquée l'ensemble des
transactions entre la russie reste du
monde les empêcher d'avoir accès au
système swift même s'il y avait des
alternatives aurait exactement cet effet
comme on a fait avec l'iran en 2012 et
un 2018 qui décide de cela
alors le système swift est une
entreprise qui est hébergé en belgique
mais qui écornent fac est ok copropriété
d'à peu près tous les membres toutes les
banques membres dessus 6e sud donc l'une
des difficultés aussi à mettre en oeuvre
une sanction via le système sous x c'est
qu'il faut recueillir une sorte
d'unanimité parmi ses membres qu'on va
exclure la rue girard évidemment la
pression des états unis la pression de
l'union européenne pourraient jouer un
rôle important dans l'obtention de ce
consensus mais il n'empêche que ont
assez espèce de gouvernance un peu
particulière qui viennent qui joue qui
tient au rôle extrêmement centrale que
rôle que joue aujourd'hui le système
swift dans le système bancaire mondial
il ya de nombreux pays qui ont annoncé
donc décembre des sanctions y compris le
canada toutes sortes de type de sanction
mais notamment des sanctions qui visent
directement le chef de l'état vladimir
poutine on vise également sergueï lavrov
quand on dit qu'on vit ces personnes-là
congèle leurs avoirs
c'est pas des gens qui manquent de
ressources en prison mais ça veut dire
quoi exactement
concrètement par exemple la fortune
personnelle de vladimir poutine va être
sous forme de différentes différents
types d'actifs qui peuvent être des
biens immobiliers comme on en a
l'habitude qui peuvent être aussi des
biens mobiliers des participations dans
les entreprises si on est capable
d'identifier ses actifs ce qui n'est pas
toujours le casque et même en fait je
dirais probablement assez rarement le
cas et pour la dîme gym je pense qu'on
ne on ne voit qu'une très petite
fraction de ses actifs réels on est
capable de dire ses actifs là pour
l'instant sont mis sous une seule et
judiciaire et ne pourront être heureux
donner à leurs propriétaires car un
certain nombre de conditions qui seront
décidées dans une résolution du conflit
arthur cl c'est très intéressant vous
êtes c'est très clair merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
merci à vous au revoir monsieur fillion
au revoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
oh